foreign
good morning happy Cod launch day I'm
David amadi video producer here at
Gamespot and we've got a great one for
you campaign fans we have the early
access to the campaign for Call Of Duty
Modern Warfare 2 to get this campaign
The Early Access for it you had to
pre-order and we managed to get it
pre-loaded the night before and we're
here now and uh ready to see what task
141 is up to so pop off in the chat we
are going Live on YouTube I'm myself I'm
going to be playing Jean-Luc is going to
be sitting here later with me and we're
just going to be having a good time
playing this campaign so
we can just dive right into it I think
right I'm just gonna pop right into it
let's let's do it
uh what do I want to do realism I'm just
kidding uh we'll start with we'll start
with regular
just uh so we can enjoy the you know
enjoy the campaign a bit let's see what
we got
oh yeah here we go
oh that looks good
Gold Eagle actual Shadow one is weapons
hot
we're burning daylight here coffee
Graves standby oh Shepard
you bastard
are you in position
nearly there
oh man we're going right into it
Simon ghost Riley
dude the lighting on this is insane
right now I mean I'm playing in 4k right
now guys and it is it is looking nice
over and Hardware or Russian
s
we need positive ID on cobrani before we
kick this off boy
ghost
you identify the general
can I identify the general where is he
it's probably going to be in the middle
of it all right
ghost get your glass in there and find
the general yeah yeah yeah shepherdham
looking for him
and I got this Outpost just loaded up
oh yeah right there
will be the last time they do
foreign
all right
man what's up
chat say hello to Jean Luke
the chat here hell yeah
fish little general cabrani
oh okay you ready
thank you
[Music]
Brandon what's up
oh all right we are oh [ __ ] steering
this missile I'm gonna get myself some
audio sure
giving me a chance to invert the
controls no dice
ah there we go
[Music]
oh yeah
direct Target destroyed
foreign
oh yeah get that film grain
I'd love to see it
I'm hit or miss on it I think sometimes
I don't mind it but I know that I like
it better when they give you an option
to like reduce or increase the levels
like you can kind of fine tune it a bit
you know what I mean yeah totally so
it's not just like overbearing what
about you
uh yeah I think it depends on the game
sometimes it feels like um I get what
they're going for it's like a film look
but I think a lot of times it just
distracts
I like when my game looks really sharp
yeah
he wants retaliation for the gorani
strike
he's planning something
we can't take him in Iran
he's not in
he's on the ground in all masra what the
hell is he doing in our room there is
only one way to find out sir
well let's get him take him out
what time is it now yeah I almost expect
Call of Duty o'clock yeah
[Laughter]
I was expecting to be like 10 seconds
ago like
oh let's go so
okay I have a question is
Alex was the main guy from the first one
right from the last one yes is he dead
no okay because he like was dead at the
end of The Campaign and then they had
like a a war zone update where they're
like he's back and I was like is that
just for Warzone or is is he actually no
it was it was there was a whole um thing
with Warzone like that continued the
story kind of interesting and it ended
with them like averting like nuclear
disaster and it was like Farah price and
everyone you know gotcha as someone who
like
plays The Campaign but then doesn't keep
up with that stuff it's like
yeah that's like confusing to me where
I'm just like oh [ __ ] am I do I have to
pay attention the whole year yeah yeah
cool though for I guess for those who
are into that mm-hmm
they're gonna uh continue the plot of
this campaign as well after this
campaign's done like it's gonna go on
the spec ops and like the raids and
things like that
raids right
[Music]
night vision goggles oh yeah here we go
here we go yeah give me that chat
you know what's crazy is like
these Graphics are so nice and yet when
you look back at like the old Modern
Warfare 2 the way that I viewed Modern
Warfare 2 back then is like how I'm
seeing this game now you know what I
mean yeah yeah 100 yeah you always you
remember the older games I was literally
thinking that the other day I was like
damn I remember like modern warfare one
and two looking like mind-blowing and
you look back at them now and they're
like yeah they look like 15 year old
games exactly exactly
I think that it both simultaneously
shows how far Graphics have come but
also how uh poorly realism Graphics age
yeah yeah
no first we clear first son that takes
the heat off
Ravi HD wants to know if it's possible
in the trophies achievements in Early
Access I would assume so probably well I
mean we'll find out at the end of this
Mission most likely all right yeah do
you have your notifications for
achievements on I turn that off oh yeah
no I think I have mine off because for
capture it's annoying yeah um although I
I do get I still know I got it because
um my computer will make a little sound
oh yeah I should turn that off it's
actually really annoying because they
like sync up right like the game bar and
all that yeah
um but I also have like my desktop and
my laptop on so I get like two pings
it's
sweet it's weird
okay
I thought that was our dude for a second
they had like night vision too I was
like oh [ __ ]
where are we going boys
I like that the default aim down sight
he like tilts it for the laser that's
really cool oh [ __ ]
I'm so busy looking at the sights
from building two second deck so uh
obviously we're like still super early
we literally just started this thing but
uh I guess uh if anyone in the chat is
watching
um has any questions for us or you know
obviously damn dude
Vince Lombardi Vince Lombardi what
that's it what why Vince Lombardi that's
a weird that's so funny get him get him
get him
it's like winning isn't everything dude
that was my um
because you didn't play Modern Warfare
one when it came out you played like
after right but uh the original one yeah
yeah yeah I played Modern Warfare 2
first in high school and then I went
back to Modern Warfare the thing that
like was so fascinating about the first
modern warfare was how cynical it was
compared to
um yeah like Call of Duty 2. because
like Call of Duty 2
um also had all the quotes right it's
been a thing since like the beginning
and they would have like quotes from
like you know uh uh like Winston
Churchill and you know all that you like
all these generals and you know like
very positive uplifting quotes and then
in Modern Warfare when you died it would
be like quotes from Dick Cheney
that were like clearly meant to be very
cynical and I was like wow what a
difference a slash whistle for no reason
that's so yeah no exactly that's so
funny
oh
nice
nice
there's one in that hallway
of ghost enemy Rockets down
solid copy good work
I love soap oh no no not this again
we're back in clean house like
shut up
they're gonna need a new hero
dude I love soap's voice yeah
all right
now we can secure the crash site can you
play it for free someone wants to know
definitely not
so I'm trying to invite you to Destiny 2
right now no no no no uh he was creating
an lfg group but it came up that's
that's funny though that'd be that's
amazing like all right guys I guess
we're playing uh we're gonna do a Raiden
yeah we're gonna do raid let's check out
the new Halloween event yeah let's
Midway switch oh dude iPad no time to
play any of that stuff right now
seriously
now we are I mean at least for me it's
all Cod all week all month really until
like warsim comes out in November
what's up what's up
damn good to see you guys we got 5K IA
one wounded it's just my gun I'm low on
ammo help me move him
no time there we are get your gun on
that tree line
if you see anything
nope
that's why I'm looking at like the wrong
wrong way
everyone's just like hunkered down
altitude's just like given like Alpha
three a side eye like this [ __ ] guy
I had like three shots and I couldn't
take it so I was just [ __ ] laughing
see anything nope
it's so good this is so good whoa
you cannot
they're getting close
[Applause]
oh there's approximately mines I could
put down
be clear for now
stay sharp on that tree line
they're still moving out there
cool for fire I want close air on that
tree line Raj
I'll dig in that
zero seven Cas is three minutes out
Roger that
just gotta hunker down for like three
minutes
oh
this reminds me of that mission in uh
call dd2 oh
you're playing that game
for no I played a big red one
um for a little bit but I don't I don't
remember it though all you do too is is
like a masterpiece in my opinion really
that game's hella good oh hell yeah
you got in the fire
I don't know what this SMG is but I
really like it if anyone in the chat
remembers Call of Duty too
shout out shout out
dude that was a 360 launch game or at
least very close to it I remember really
I thought it was like a
I thought it was like a PS2 gamecubera
no no no no
um
it was it was uh Call of Duty 2 was a
launch game for the um
the 360
um I believe wow I think big I think
Call of Duty 2 big Red One was a PS2
game yeah yeah yeah yeah but that was
like made by a different Studio
gotcha gotcha gotcha
ghost
s even back then Activision was still
doing that like we'll make multiple Call
of Duties with different Studios
um
seven actual kilo zero one fire is One
mic out kilo zero one you're cleared hot
on anything forward of our position
danger close approved
LT we got armored vehicles incoming oh
no
serve your ammo
boss
there's some mines out there
I like that just in case
nice
air supports on station
oh wow oh there you go
this guy's got her back
oh yeah
so what's happening in this game
Roger that 7-6 yeah okay I mean war war
yeah like like Modern Warfare Modern
Warfare exactly
I mean it seems like we're chasing down
that uh the general right now because we
were like okay maybe he's in Iran and he
was like no no he's not in Iran he's
actually in Al mazara was he in uh no I
don't think so it's like a totally new
dude okay
um but yeah what's funny is that El
mazara is actually like the map for war
zone 2.0
um yeah I think it's like I think the
General's name's like Hassan and we're
trying to
take him dead or alive I don't know if
it's gonna give me the choice
um I'm pretty sure we we we're about
American though I don't think you take
him in alive Okay so
they've kind of already brought in a
bunch of characters from Modern Warfare
2. so
um
uh hopefully wrote shows up somewhere oh
yeah I would love that is Makarov in
this timeline oh
um macro of the enemy right yeah he's
the big bad of of two and three right
right right
um I don't not yet I don't think okay
yeah just curious yeah yeah for sure I'm
fascinated by like how much of this is
like fits into the timeline right yeah
like the parallels between the two
versions and what they take and what
they change exactly because characters
like Alex and pharah are obviously
completely different
um
yeah that makes sense for sure I think
it's um
Makarov who is Modern Warfare ones
villain it was Zacchaeus gotcha yeah a
Makarov was like
his Protege kind of or like
um
I think Makarov was the guy who sold oh
it's okay this you gotta snipe the [ __ ]
yeah there was no place for me to for
what I remember is like Makarov worked
with zakayov and I think he like sold
him stuff ah gotcha gotcha gotcha a
professional relationship you might say
exactly
where is this other sniper I cannot oh
my God he's got me oh
no I don't know where I'm looking at
[Music]
oh I got a checkpoint which is nice
I got the guy on the roof
I feel like this other guy might be oh
there he is there he is
nice there you go
what's this mission's name do you know I
think it's oh damn there's another one I
guess oh yeah
deal with that first
why is he where is he
[Music]
cannot
see him
Izzy like a little lower maybe yeah
potentially
I feel like I mean they gotta be like in
a window or something right or like
behind some kind of cover
where the [ __ ]
I'm not crazy right like
I'm gonna stand up and see
oh my God it is so hard to see
oh oh okay right side
right side there he is guys
keep us covered we're moving out okay
dude great cover man
now
at least these guys have lasers and kind
of like
that's all where they're at
not level that doesn't actually work
like that in real life right I don't
think so yeah I was gonna say I'm pretty
sure that's
or like if it does it would have to be
like
um did I feel like smoke or something to
like properly see it you know yeah
there's like like it can work but like
there's it's not just like oh
they have lasers because if they did
that would be a huge tactical
disadvantage for them exactly you're
just giving your your own position away
especially from that distance yeah I get
like Close Quarters it could be you know
easier to like process
but yeah from this far away it's like
what are you doing
yeah you might well be like waving a
glow stick yeah
yeah but I think I think the mission's
called like killer capture or something
like that okay
it's either yeah it's either killer
capture or dead or alive it's like one
of them
some kind of ultimatum of like moving
into by any means necessary type
situation oh
oh
here uh
nice
putting positive ID on his side
drop one
if anyone have eyes oh my God is that a
hookah that's hilarious
classic card was great hell yeah
do this like yeah the classic like World
War II FPS games really hold a
a nostalgic like spot in my heart for me
was like Medal of Honor the old Medal of
Honor games yeah medal of honor front
line European Assault love that love
that stuff
and I I I didn't like the
I didn't play Vanguard
um but I didn't like the World War II
Sledgehammer one all that much because
um
it
I don't know it's just like it didn't
have that same
it wasn't necessarily the setting that
made like Call of Duty 2 so good it was
like
I don't know there's something about
like the precinct like it was it was
something else
um it's kind of hard to describe
uh
she did
oh he was about to blow himself up
oh where'd that guy come from I don't
know but that's gnarly so they said s
vest I guess that means a suicide vest
wow that's rough
locked
can I like blast it open no okay oh oh
they locked me in
oh those bastards can I like no I can't
I was like they locked me in and then
chucked a a freaking grenade
Jake Duggar says damn they got you
hunting Hassan [ __ ]
[Laughter]
oh well couldn't throw it back all right
I'm just
there it goes
oh I love video game logic
yeah this is just like a SWAT rate like
someone's just like uh swatted his his
twitch stream that's what this is
actually yeah
doing his live stream
I'm really oh [ __ ] are bad yeah yeah my
bad my bad my bad
love you love you love your show I love
you love your work it's probably Andrew
Tate crying about it
oh that's
everywhere everywhere over here
those are like Close Quarter
assassinations are so gnarly oh
what's up buddy
he's already dead
kill confront
that was another room entirely I think
you know I'm generally curious how many
people are actually gonna
bother with the whole like getting this
early to get access to the campaign
because what it's not just the is it the
base version or do you have to buy like
the special
um good question I I think even the base
version we'll give you the Early Access
oh really yeah so it's just pre-order it
I think it's just pre-order it I mean
you could double check uh you know just
make sure I'm not just like completely
misremembering but
um yeah I think the idea is that they
wanted people to maybe get through the
campaign so when multiplayer comes out
everyone can just pop into multiplayer
right off the bat without feeling left
out you know yeah but well it also gives
people who normally would never play the
campaign it kind of encourages them to
play because it's like well what else am
I gonna do and it gives me a chance to
maybe feel out some guns yeah you know
um
yeah that's a that's a great uh let's
see here that's a great point
um
let's clear it
still blinded big time
yeah it seems like it's any version they
don't specify you need a specific
version to do it they don't specify if
it's Vault or no it just says pre-order
and get it so I I assume that means it's
just you you get the campaign right
right
right
how is he not dead holy [ __ ]
that guy was a tank and a half
like a dolphin dive in here too
I was gonna say yeah you're a little low
an animal yeah
oh
yeah
yeah
all clear
search it let's find what they were
hiding
this Warehouse wasn't on the Intel
what they got what's see
you want to let me in Mr
Mr Corporal the fields
uh to get an achievement for starting
all those laptops I have no idea but
that's that was the thing in Modern
Warfare too yeah yeah you had to shoot
all of the I think it was one as well
right it was like it's okay it was uh
yeah that sounds right the speech or
whatever but yeah if you like shot all
the TVs that were like broadcasting it
yeah you would you know draw the
container see if it's locked
what the [ __ ] is this
it's all in English
7-6 gas through to Laswell Roger standby
bravo 7-6 charlie to watch her one how
copy this is what you won sent traffic
last well this is Ghost we've got
something
tell me you found us on ghost
take a look at this
negative we found a weapon the bad guys
are yeah we're the Baddies
this is old eagle
repeat your last I'll say again the Sun
as American missiles
hmm all right clear the room ah here he
is
now oh so that was I thought that was a
different General but that's Shepard
okay oh people are saying the Vault
version only
we can chat oh gotcha okay that makes
sense
or no but then someone else is saying
it's any version of possession of
American missiles American missiles and
aq's hands his son has been passing out
our ballistic missiles like it's [ __ ]
Halloween and we didn't know about it
Jesus Christ
all over this do you check her Halloween
candy yeah it might be ballistic
missiles in it
check your kids Halloween candy it's
very important
negative I want them destroyed
General hmm hey Shepard yeah why do you
want them destroy it yeah
well 500 enemy soldiers on that site by
Sunrise we need a win fast
well he's a very different looking
character than that he is yeah I was
like where's his mustache
and his hair
Sports and canals are insecure Iran has
friends
who
the captain
the captain
there he is
I like that he's just got the captain
yeah yeah that's his moniker
Michael asks is this out yes it is so if
you pre-order the game you get early
access to the campaign yes
until then
you keep this tight
naturally although it's I like the
phrasing of it like pre-order I don't
know is it really a pre-order at that
point if you could just at any point now
buy and get the campaign yeah versus
like I guess it's your perspective it's
like I care about the multiplayer so I'm
pre-ordering the multiplayer and getting
early access to the campaign or I'm just
buying the campaign now and then I just
get the multiplayer week later yeah yeah
my point is video game uh like
terminology around marketing stuff is
like so bizarre it's weird nonsense so
bizarre
so that's crazy because Gaz in 2019 was
uh being referred to as Kyle right
Sergeant Kyle or whatever and
I like never made the connection that
you know his name was uh his name was
Gaz until like the final cutscene Modern
Warfare when they like mentioned like oh
yeah this is Sergeant Kyle we call him
gas or whatever oh yeah yeah that was
their thing
well that's where we're in position
was ghost in the last one too
no not until uh like Warzone season one
or two or whatever and then he just came
on as like an operator but in but in
Modern Warfare
wait wait sorry did you see Modern
Warfare two sorry no the last one 2019
oh yeah yeah
um yeah no he was not on the campaign no
he was alluded to in the final cutscene
though because like when he's pulling
out the dosier showing all the uh
players ghost is just like a blank face
so
I'll meet you at a barge check
when you can do you remember that whole
theory in in the original version where
people thought ghost was Gaz in the
original Modern Warfare too because they
have the same voice actor oh really yeah
because Gaz dies at the end of the first
modern warfare oh yeah okay okay okay
okay I remember this now and so there
was like ghost and everyone and but he
had the same voice actors gas everyone
was like yo that's really gas like but
then I don't think that ever yeah I
don't even remember what happened to
ghost in Modern Warfare 2. I think he
got I think he got got oh but I don't
fully recall
[Music]
okay Ravi says trophy list is up but I
don't know if they can be earned yet
there's a trophy for shooting three
enemies in this Mission while being
underwater so if you want to go for it
shooting yes like you're underwater and
you like okay
so I guess if uh you have the
opportunity we can try it and see if we
get it seems like I only have a knife
available oh well okay maybe a little
later then unless there's like a a
throwing knife thing that I could
potentially do I don't know there is a
throwing knife thing but I don't know if
you could throw a knife in the that
wouldn't really work oh yeah yeah the
physics of that physics of that would
not would be impossible yeah
I mean I'm sure like
oh wait oh wait it gave you the option
yeah oh come on
that would not work oh it didn't work it
didn't work okay
I was like no way oh
try it again I want I really want to see
if it works okay well that guy's I think
you're a dude
I don't know is that your dude no that's
not I don't know okay let's see
no no okay
[Laughter]
uh someone sort of an issue where it
says missing DLC pack uh are people
having trouble yeah this is uh you guys
have a problem with the game says I'm
missing a DLC pack how do I fix it I
press this all nothing happens
unfortunately I'm not really sure yeah
you didn't have that pop-up right no no
no no DLC pack my issue was it kept
telling me that we were too early yeah
and then we just restarted the Xbox and
it worked exactly yeah at the very least
I would I would maybe restart the Xbox
or your system I guess you're playing on
and see if that does anything yeah
so you can retrieve your throwing knife
again totally sad
uh
you should grab a gun from those guys
right yeah yeah oh yeah yes I could try
shooting from underwater right
let's do that
yeah yeah those are all Silas weapons
too
okay so the achievement was do they have
to be underwater too or I just have to
be underwater uh
this is wild being underwater okay
that's what Ravi in the chat says so we
got one dude here
oh it is not letting me shoot
bummer oh really yeah
oh okay
nope interesting yeah
but you could attempt to throw a knife
underwater yeah right weird oh you know
what it is I just realized it's
um
it's only pistols I think
I want to say
see if they have a pistol yeah
someone got a pistol for me
oh that guy's pistol yeah okay
oh with 12 bullets there we go okay
all right let's do it yeah let's do it
yeah yeah gone one yeah I said yeah I
only have a handgun God check out you
only works with handguns okay
I think there is a guy over to your left
yeah
we're at uh to your right 180.
a little bit to your left
over there yeah
yeah
I'm fine just trying to
murder some people underwater
like over here
yeah I saw them on your little your
compass
Elm okay they disappeared weird weird
oh that's a guy
over there oh no never mind that's a
boat oh well there's a guy there's a guy
there okay
I saw the little um the the little
floaty on that
all right here we go
all right pop him
did not
I know you're there
get him get him get him get him get him
there you go that's one
the trajectory was so weird Okay other
dudes here yeah
all right
get him
nice it's two
nice I got some more ammo let's find one
more dude
oh uh oh yeah
oh okay
all right well let me kill this guy
first price and then I'll uh
that might be them
okay
Jesus Christ
I just want to kill the other two guys
that might be them like price that might
be why
um
okay all right price who the [ __ ] did I
leave alive where is he
oh
hello it is so hard how does price now
yeah right
okay
yeah we get it we get it we get it yeah
yeah
okay all right
get his ass
oh oh underneath the water yeah
there we go
no achievement pop
no nope all right then
either you have your notifications off
or they do not pop or they do not pop
yeah or or maybe that first shot that oh
hey nice job
[Laughter]
I love when achievements are delayed
like that especially when it's like
you're trying to get a really specific
achievement and then you're like did I
get it did I get it what the hell and
then
foreign what's fun about early acts is
that every achievement is like a rare
achievement too oh on Xbox you get that
like extra diamonds
type thing which feels really cool
I like the name of that achievement too
crocodile
it's a pretty good one
all right
right with you sergeant
I'm just gonna pop up behind them
oh I guess there's more people over
there
swimming's really weird yeah yeah
how so it's kind of annoying I like it
though the way that I'm bobbing it's
like hard for me to uh try to like get
an angle it's like a momentum to the way
you move yeah exactly what you're saying
oh oh
it took forever to mantle up that was
yeah that's definitely the thing
difficulty we are and you're just on the
normal right I'm not normal yeah it's
not it's not too big all right there you
go yeah yeah I think he'll be better off
yeah this will be easier yeah
he was just waiting the whole time I
think you can do it
oh you missed one yeah you gonna help no
yeah
as well we're about to board
Michael says the best part of working
from home is I'll be playing this in
five minutes oh hell yeah we won't tell
your boss Michael yeah
with us
you do what you got to do oh yeah now
price is going freaking thing on your uh
right
Flashman eggs
Mexican cartel oh wow okay everyone's
playing all right
stand by
you could have warned me price yeah oh
have you got that shotgun in oh yeah
yeah where was it earlier up here yeah
yeah oh yeah
do another flash for good measure nice
let's go get [ __ ] oh it is dark about
very dark yeah
it doesn't help that we're in a studio
with lots of yeah
I don't wanna I don't want to like bring
it out too much else again it's kind of
hard to see sometimes but
Graphics still look fine though oh yeah
it's really really pretty oh someone
trapped
oh
not anymore I guess
oh it was his phone I thought that was
like a whimper when I first heard that
what you got on you bro
it's just like from his mom like love
you I can't wait to
are you coming are you coming home for
dinner are you coming for dinner
um
uh I hope you're ready for dad's funeral
next week
your sister's very excited to see you
yeah yeah yeah the dog misses you oh
it's a picture of like his pet or
something yeah
oh what is this what's going on here
1206 to what you want this is n't the
cafe
was my three o'clock where are we
what are they up to
conducting a transaction
they're paying the cartel for something
to figure out what what up even gal even
Gall I think that's how you say your
name how's it going man
you guys are making that too sad
this is Modern Warfare
Roger that
oh okay I'm doing like like a
a CIA type Mission I always like these
these missions kind of break up the
pacing yeah you walk around
wow this place looks yeah look at look
at those shops on the right I'm kind of
Cafe Nicholas there was a uh I think
this might be it yeah
there we go erotic nightclub live sex
theater hell yeah let's go hell yeah
Pilsner
the Red Toad coffee shop
tobacco shop this is clearly like not I
feel like this is not
I don't know where this place is did you
say it was Lebanon
maybe something like that oh look at it
ah
so pretty European cities look so
beautiful yeah
yeah the Cobble Pathways and stuff out
of super walkable like bridges over
Canada dude yeah American cities suck
ass our cities suck so bad oh that's a
cartel guy one's leaving
uh I got here late has ghost shown up
yet yeah ghost has been around since the
beginning he was um
uh the first mission we did you play
soap and uh ghost is with you but hold
on
no alcohol in public spaces 100 fine
Jesus
meanwhile that kid's just dancing over
there yeah yeah
[Laughter]
it means he's in Mexico
oh really
uh okay we're to now regroup with
Laswell near the cafe all right
I've never seen that sign before
it's like hold your children's hand
basically
just like watch your children watch your
kids I guess
because God's alone
we need a destruction
oh yeah
what you got price
retrieved the distraction device from
Price oh hey what's up buddy
you uh you want to give me
you want to give me that
the bloody hell is this decoy good night
as well
put it in that kid's jacket
decoy grenade it'll work
down the alley all right when Panic
starts to describe
okay
oh I'm gonna put it in uh okay
okay
[ __ ] you
go sit down then you'll wake up
meet you at the bridge
Mr Ryan said that one scene where the
nuke went off in Black Ops 2 or what Cod
was it that was um
Modern Warfare 3 is what I know
well there's a scene of my Warfare 3
where uh like a truck blows up and kills
like a kid
um which
I thought that scene was so lame I
remember that in my opinion um
nuke going off uh
uh there was a nuke going off in Modern
Warfare 2. yeah but that was like where
you're the astronaut
that was so funny I heard just like just
just some random astronaut who gets
totally like destroyed well he gets like
shot back and then he's just drifting in
space and dies horribly and you're like
oh man all right [ __ ] that guy
oh
yeah all right
not playing around
meet you at the bridge
I'm moving in
shut your mouth follow me
what you want pack it secure head in
your way puppy
it's hard cause I like cannot shoot
citizens like oh my God yeah yeah you're
just getting
there's got to be a better spot for me
to like maybe we'll just like chill
behind this thing here
's a lot how do these people like no
one's noticing any of this
nice
oh
good Lord man all right yeah you're
gonna need to like fine covering yeah
yeah
this is
Roach
es
nice
there you go yeah yeah I appreciate that
it says cartel yeah that's that's makes
it way nicer nice
play with a mouse and keyboard at least
Jesus for playing on uh Xbox
um right now yeah I mean you can plug in
a mouse and keyboard on Xbox yeah yeah
now we're doing controller because
um just the where studio is set up it's
easier
um yeah controller I mean I would like
to have a a nice setup in here with
mouse and keyboard oh I'm I'm looking uh
forward to playing this game on my PC oh
same dude yeah it's gonna be so nice
oh damn she's gonna go girl boss on him
oh so that was Amsterdam Amsterdam
song
terrorists don't cross the southern
border we know that and they know that
and that is exactly why they're gonna do
it I need you to stop it who's my target
copy when
python
[Applause]
he's got movement down there
withdrawals responding
instructions
FBI is an hour out right now you're all
we got standby
wonderful
destruction
foreign
let me see the other guy next to him
yeah possibly
check we're getting a remastered no
Russian in this game I highly doubt it
okay I'm the Alejandro's buddy
you're the other guys Rodolfo
OT
I do like the whole like swapping
swapping perspectives constantly so good
I love that
although I do miss the um how each
character in like OG Modern Warfare 2
had their own like symbol you know like
you were the SAS sir
and all that uh during the like debrief
before YouTube Oh in Modern Warfare one
it was like you're the SAS and this
you're the Americans and at the end it
like this the logos like fused together
it was so sick I loved that yeah
foreign
a month ago yeah
yeah oh wow that's beautiful
so now we're on U.S territory basically
I think oh that's what it sounds like
which we're technically not supposed to
yeah we have no jurisdiction very like
Hush Hush yeah exactly they get caught
there's no helping them kind of thing
also super appreciate their speaking
Spanish the whole time yes
yes
oh
no
are they killing innocence
where are they
really quick when it said de-escalate I
thought if I press the left trigger
maybe I would like talk them down be
like hey guys like like it's okay
my trigger was literally just aiming the
gun at them and being like get the [ __ ]
back in here yeah man that's the
escalating
I'm just gonna break into some uh
hello
I love how the cartels are just like
[ __ ] off gringo
Special Forces Special Forces
I was not expecting them to do this many
of these types of missions up front
don't shoot
the man who came through here where did
they go
hello
thank you
oh that's the bathroom oh yeah
just gotta head out yeah
oh I'm sorry probably just through there
yeah so it says clean house is back yeah
the first mission also had a clean house
moment like they're doing it like
multiple times yeah yeah
Roger oh
it's definitely tense like I'm like
I was about to say like he could just
turn and hit you and he totally did
so
it's like a Resident Evil 4 moment yeah
okay yeah yeah
that's so funny dude
I think he's still
I don't know you got it you got him oh
did we okay
I wasn't sure it is so hard to see yeah
very sorry no it's okay
he was running at me with like a machete
and everything
we need to get like a I think they
they're rtvs that are like no glare
um but they're like super super rare
like only a couple people make them oh
yeah or they might just be for monitors
too yeah true and I'm sure they're just
really expensive
grab the shotgun that I walked over
here
not here to hurt you I'm looking for
someone
the man who came through here where is
he hey Holden
oh
medical civilian down
what damn okay
you know why I think that happened
because I took my my gun off them for a
second because the moment that I moved
away it said like hey de-escalate again
but by then it was too late I think if I
kept my gun on them they wouldn't it
could have been a way to avoid it
that's gnarly that is gnarly
foreign
[Music]
step forward to me I want to see empty
hands above your head I will shoot you
if I have to bro
chill
s
after a known terrorist Gomez hold up
these are her guys
hard to tell you boys apart from Cartel
you can't even process the uh a little
bit of racism in there oh
shh get a little bit of racism than an
explosion
oh my God
oh yeah this is escalated
yeah it is uh I'd maybe grab that yeah
yeah
screw man use that grenade launcher
yeah oh
there he is
oh what that didn't get him
oh no oh yeah I did
it's so funny
all right yeah I'm going in
uh probably through the front door
oh
my God
interesting that that was a game over
though
right
I think because that lady no matter what
would not have been able to shoot me
whereas the the other two dudes yeah so
it was like a defense situation but
still one that could have been for sure
avoidable
not from this hallway where did that
dude go
do you like hide through the door maybe
yeah he's got to be in uh
yep damn
I'm not gonna lie I really like
I really like this like these missions
it's it's just it's so different from
the usual like Run and Gun chaos of it
all you know
go up the stairs let's see what we got
hey you ever play um
you ever play SWAT four
I've never played just walking
uh I mean the rest of them or whatever
but swap four is is a very good game oh
yeah um but it's like
this the game where it's it's like
SWAT team like you know tactically
busting in houses like Corners yeah yeah
I mean even more tactical than this but
like it's
um Jesus
wow
is that me
yeah that's me
did our other guy get shot
no Alejandro said he was watching the
outside
yeah yeah yeah you're you're dude's dead
I'm
no
more
atlantico
oh nice okay
I was about to be like damn that's
[ __ ] I was about to be really sad yeah
oh man this game's gnarly dude yeah
what the hell
my special forces confirmed Hassan
Hassan is moving something sizable
towards the
Street he's lying down we need to
capture Hassan and bring him in for
interior all right at 11 40. so we
probably do it we'll go for like another
20. maybe call it there okay one more
Mission yeah yeah one more Mission
sounds about right I'll show you too
much but you know yeah
yeah we're not gonna blast the whole
game no
but this has been this has been fun this
has been really cool like yeah
yeah I mean this is what only two
missions in two and a half kind of
missions in if you count the CIA one you
know yeah whole thing like
nice
actually I believe he performs
welcome to the city of Seoul what was
that
never been to Mexico in Mexico
's contractors are inbound to reinforce
they're bringing Hardware they'll need
room my face is your race good now I
love that soap's like
not quite like a grizzled veteran here
yet you know like he behaves kind of
young you know what I mean like he's
just yeah well he's starting out kind of
it's like he's got a little more
presence than like modern warfare one
obviously right where he was like the
rookie but he's not like leader of his
own Squad the way he wasn't too exactly
yeah it's kind of in between he's in the
middle the moment when you first see him
in Modern Warfare 2 and he's just like
smoking when the Jets pass by then he
looks at you he's like all right breaks
over roach let's go everything about
that delivery was so like I've seen [ __ ]
you know oh yeah
many of those
with corruption disappear what about the
military
because we're well drained soldiers are
recruited by the narcos why not you
grew up here
Cowboys
I love this place
thank you
kids got some balloons there's a new one
nautical news generosity to win over the
people even the children especially the
children
hey Rodolfo nice oh
[Music]
cartel clothes
warnings marking territory okay the
cartel is like a big presence in this
game more than I I then I thought yeah
Mercy nombre nameless
Carter where can we find them you can't
no one knows who he is
but he is everywhere and this is a
challenge
like challenges
with their mask you will fit in well if
you go
check voice
they are turn right we'll go around
just expecting ghosts to say that'll do
like every other uh every other line now
across the river
let's hope he's still there
Ah that's pretty makes me think of a
Forza actually Forza Horizon five
there's like
a section where those really beautiful
colored like yeah
Villages are
my son
yeah a little fist bump for luck let's
go
my soap now
let's see we're trying to see yeah
enter
oh so let's go
good place to keep us on
move
damn
through the window yeah
those are guys in the back
Jonathan says he's getting uh sicario
vibes from this yes seriously that feels
like a big influence for this oh yeah
let me move faster heads up
take the door
hey I think I hurt
my son could be anywhere
[Music]
nice
oh that ain't working
oh
yeah
clear
what happened to the family's here
they leave get ready to move
standby
where's your family Alejandro
I keep that a secret Hermano
protect them
we have concealment
let's move
on myself
this is where they were hiding us on
expect resistance
nice oh that's a beautiful looking door
yeah tough it's a bummer
oh there's another one there oh well I
just
[ __ ] it up a little bit
is he dead I think so
she was staring at you
sunglasses threw me off just sitting
there
oh
nice
in this room
I'll cover
oh yeah I got some flashbangs
got some ammo nice
this whole game just gonna be like
Hassan's on that building he's not here
because that's like what all these three
like missions have been so far yeah yeah
we got reinforcements
fall back
you want us to engage the [ __ ]
Mexican Army
these troops are paid by the cartel
they're helping the cartel protect us on
Hold Your Fire
will they gain into my Manor clear
multiple Vehicles troop transport to
light armor
hold fire
let them get close
weapons free
oh Frida Kahlo
dude these quotes are killing me
Plus
nice clothes
are you throw a grenade yeah
it's a long reload
foreign
oh no did the game crash
yeah I did oh [ __ ] right when it was
getting good oh no
damn
uh uh
[ __ ] man that's tough that's rough uh
someone chat outside of the campaign so
far pretty good up until that crashed
there
um let's see if it'll hop us right back
in yeah yeah if it boots this like a
while back maybe uh that'll call it but
it should it should be uh yeah usually
checkpoints checkpoints are pretty
pretty good yeah
Early Access indeed
all right I mean it was it was pretty
good up until that point right yeah
seemed like it was fine
okay updating playlists
for the campaign playlist campaign
playlist I guess
resume resume
well okay
okay cool it's like right here yeah yeah
all right there we go jump out that
window all right after you uh Mr Vargas
let him go okay all right there we go
there we go
I'm getting shot from the back oh yeah
we just ran by an entire like Platoon
[Music]
that sucks we're getting shot from like
two different directions now
[Music]
are we clear
for now we gotta move go
you know these trails
they will Marcel says it's gonna work
without internet connection you mean the
game
um probably not I don't think so yeah
in general I want to say the Xbox can
kind of license stuff gets weirdly on
the internet which I
really hate yeah
[Applause]
foreign
nope oh there's some guys up there too
yeah
I know our boy
oh
that guy
oh no
Jesus
[Laughter]
all right yeah definitely get that guy
yeah
there we go
nice nice nice nice nice
uh over on your left
dude they're like bulletproof this is
like kind of
and that's something I'm used to that's
crazy
they're almost like it's like you're
fighting someone in war zone kind of hmm
yeah is that there was like a little
like
is that what that was okay it's it's
when they when their Armor gets like
interesting yeah that's interesting
seeing that in the campaign right
get a little uh little action there
we're too Alejandro
so push forward Rodriguez keep working
the radio the rest of you watch for
snipers use that wage they will
they were good
I'm the jumper believe me
I think he wants me to jump
in early see get to a firing position
okay
to the bridge straight ahead
and try to cut us off we'll have to go
through them
unideal
take the high Downs
we have another person who brought up
that DLC pack issue
um oh no sorry man you had someone else
earlier who brought that up and
unfortunately not really sure what
that's about yeah there's there's like
no simple fix for something like that
yeah
um definitely give a Google search to
see if anyone on Reddit has uh mentioned
that that's usually my go-to running
issues like that but yeah um we're
playing on Xbox we didn't have that
issue we just had to like restart the
system yeah to get it to like let it
load in
you could also check like Twitter
um Call of Duty's like help page Twitter
they might have they're usually good
about acknowledging like hey we we
realize that people are having like this
specific error or like yeah like try
doing this exactly that's my go-to's
places for that kind of that kind of
thing yeah
somebody else Sergeant we're moving
up the hill this way
I don't think so
probably that way yeah
oh maybe go around yeah
there we go
radio when we're down there this way
jump down sergeant
until the cartels moved in exactly
cut school and playing on the cliffs
that's not that's not sound great oh
[ __ ] there's a sniper
oh
oh Rodriguez get it oh
is this game new serious question yeah
man it's that new it's that new Call of
Duty it is the new Call of Duty uh out
today
uh sort of oh
um technically it's like you're
pre-ordering if you pre-order it you get
access to the campaign today
really it just means they're kind of uh
breaking the game up into multiple
chunks yep
I guess that means physical copies don't
get released today right oh
did he get shot no he jumps
jump boy oh that was a little too close
to those rocks yeah it was
[Music]
oh
I ran out of air and drowned okay I
thought I was hurt from the rocks
okay
breathing move down river to the bridge
use the rocks
videos picking up something South
America
hmm
yeah our guy's saying that uh I guess
Cod hasn't said anything about uh the
DLC issue about the DLC issue but it's
affecting consoles and PC
um yeah it's probably some sort of uh
it's like weird server error type thing
where it's got to be
not having all the deals that sounds
like a weird like authentication error
yeah
oh the water current is like moving in
it's weird I have to like push against
it to stay steady that's crazy
nice
attack
on this get shallow up ahead
playing on that train no we're actually
playing on regular fuel
you see me frankly you seem a little uh
more vulnerable on regular than I what I
remember I agree when I've played Call
of Duty before
um you hit the uh the like warning
screen really fast yeah like there's a
couple times we've just gone down like
pretty quick and I was like oh wow
that's that's kind of it feels like it
would be veteran mode you know what I
mean at times yeah
even just that alone the fact that these
enemies now are like they got the armor
they got the armor like yeah you're like
hitting that dude see now it broke like
that's yeah crazy right
I mean it's it's not a bad change I mean
because that was one of the complaints
um I think some people had about The
Campaign which was like oh it's mindless
they're Bots it's too easy you know what
I mean but like oh sure this is kind of
making them a little spongier
isn't necessarily a bad choice I think
it's kind of neat
son
to north of your position
yeah Jay kind of brings up how swimming
and shooting is always going to kind of
look and feel goofy yeah like just the
idea of like you holding up like a metal
rifle aiming down the sights and you're
like treading water like sure
there we go I think we got a little set
piece probably trying to escape
yeah let's see
yes come here no set heading for that
compound right fire officers
let's see what this mission is because
uh we are at time yeah yeah call it so
we'll kind of see what we're getting
come get me General Shepard Raj stand by
Shepherd's up sir Gold Eagle actual this
is Shadow one how copy loud and clear
Shadow one same traffic I had to bail
your boys out luckily they have friends
and I placed that's what you're there
for
we got a hit on Hassan approaching the
Target location now we'll get this
bastard rolled up for a little talking
to him that's what I like to hear from
when Hassan's in the bag Roger that out
here
all Shadows listen up these guys on the
ground Mexican Special Forces one four
one they are your brothers now treat
them like your own and let's get this
done yeah yeah all right yup yup
orbiting the compound now standing by
the fish
Shadow one Bravo zero
zero composition with
that zero seven how do we find Hassan
he'll have an on guard
a lot of places hide range covers were
close there we clear the buildings
with iot
yes
Shadow one we're east of the compound
position
yep that's a new mission
close air
do we maybe play as like I'd imagine
maybe you're playing as the pilot Modern
Warfare 2 had a mission like that
originally when you were like in the oh
yeah yeah exactly oh it is doing this
okay
all right well I think we're gonna call
it right yeah that's a good place to
call it so this is pretty good we
blasted through a good chunk it was like
four or five missions actually right
managed to get through so
[Music]
um
it'd be Call of Duty uh yeah it was kind
of a
surprise how much of those sort of like
clean house type missions they have yeah
early on all the time absolutely so many
stealth moments you know traversing
underwater trying to do stealth kills a
lot of shoot don't shoot type situations
like uh
it was fun
uh yeah Anthony Williams uh uh We're not
gonna play the whole campaign on stream
as much as I would love to
dude got some other stuff I've got to
take care of yeah yeah absolutely but
yeah man that's gonna call it here I'm
gonna go head over and turn off the
stream for sure yeah so let me do that
I'll just I'll say goodbye take a look
at this chat too while I'm here
yeah thank you guys so much for uh for
joining us by the way this was uh this
was a lot of fun I had a really really
good time
uh just you know one final thing to
remind you guys if you were interested
in playing the campaign you would have
to pre-order the game
um but a couple of folks here mentioned
that there were some issues uh logging
on so just keep that in mind but
definitely subscribe to Gamespot we're
gonna have our review on probably coming
in in a couple of weeks once you know
our reviewer gets time to handle it I'll
be making a bunch of guides doing
gameplay videos features things like
that so uh yeah thanks for joining us
and we'll see you guys around next time
so
bye-bye